for as long as The Legend of Zelda has
been a franchise the man with the evil
eyes has been there looming just to be
on the horizon waiting eagerly for a
chance to clutch at the fabled Triforce
this man is driven by dark forces from
beyond our realm to commit atrocities
against the goddesses it was revealed to
us in the prequel Skyward Sword that his
hatred has an origin the curse laid upon
the descendants of the bloodline of
hialeah and the spirit of the hero by
the demon king demise though this evil
has taken on many incarnations over the
entire history of Hyrule none stand so
prevalent as the notorious Ganondorf the
King of Thieves even though the man has
been slain across every timeline his
influence is still greatly felt as the
malicious calamity Ganon wrecked havoc
across the land in breadth of the wild
but just when we thought the Gerudo
scourge was defeated once and for all
the trailer for breath of the wild
sequel was released revealing again that
we are not yet rid of him but how what
happened to the man who has been killed
over and over again to continue to haunt
Hyrule and enable his body to snap back
to life after all this time are there
any clues we can gather from his life
before breath of the wild that may
answer some questions about what's to
come in breath of the wild - for those
of you watching both new to the
franchise and veterans of it were going
to delve into the story of Ganondorf and
piece together any significant details
from his history some of you have never
heard of Ganondorf before and others
will already know the contents of this
video by heart or will already have your
own theories to those people I asked for
you to also watch the video in its
entirety as there may be something here
you've missed or forgotten and be sure
to join the comments below to help
others who are new to the series to
understand here to join me today on this
quest through the history of Ganondorf
is the prestigious Commonwealth realm
themselves so you know this is gonna be
a fun ride and now without further ado
allow us to present Ganondorf the
journey of a thief
[Music]
ganondorf's story first begins in the
game ocarina of time the events of which
we'll be covering more in depth in the
partner video it did this one due to the
direct eyes it has to breath the wild to
but in summary as most of you know at
the end of the game Ganondorf is
defeated twice once in the adult
timeline as the sages seal him away
after he's defeated by link in his Ganon
form and once in the child timeline as
Link and Zelda are able to convince the
king of Hyrule to banish him from the
world of light however there's one
scenario which he emerges victorious in
the game a Link to the Past which is a
game that takes place after ocarina of
time in the downfall timeline where
Ganondorf third story is revealed it
states in the game that the great thief
actually slaughtered his own minions in
order to seize the Triforce for himself
of the link inadvertently opened the
door to the Sacred Realm for him once he
had his hand on the relic you wish for
total dominance of the world and thus
transformed the Sacred Realm into the
dark world the sages were successful in
sealing him inside of realm only for
Ganon to eventually break free with the
help of the wizard agony however his
plans are ultimately unsuccessful as the
hero of Hyrule defeats him with the
Master Sword and restores the Sacred
Realm ters former glory we've just
witnessed the death of Ganon the games
to follow this one in the phone timeline
are all simply attempts from the
followers of Ganon to resurrect him all
of which are stopped by link either
before he's fully resurrected or shortly
after was peculiar about this is the
fact that Ganon apparently can't be
permanently prevented from returning
that he's always showing up as Ganon and
not Ganondorf what could this mean for
both the wild - we'll get to that a
little bit later on in the video we've
explored Ganon's story in the fallen
timeline but what about the others
backtracking again to the end of ocarina
of time in the adult timeline when link
defeats Ganon and the sages are shown to
have sealed Ganondorf away he breaks out
of a seal once again in the events of
the Wind Waker but this time no hero
rose to stop him because of this he was
able to easily capture the kingdom of
Hyrule but was stopped by the goddesses
flooding of the land of
in an attempt to seal him at the bottom
of the ocean this too proved useless as
Ganondorf rose to the service and began
to build his army once again it was then
that link a young boy from outside
island sets off on his quest to find his
kidnapped sister and ends up becoming
the hero of wins and defeating Ganondorf
in the submerged kingdom of Hyrule after
plunging the fabled Master Sword into
the skull of the Gerudo King his body
turns to stone as the Master Sword
Ganondorf the king and the rest of
Hyrule are drowned too beneath the ocean
once and for all
the following games don't feature Ganon
or Ganondorf effectively killing him off
in this timeline in the final timeline
that were going to look at the child
timeline Ganondorf was banished to the
Twilight Realm after Link and Zelda are
able to convince the king of his evil
nature at the end of ocarina of time
ganondorf's luck played out once again
though because he was able to use his
own power of the Triforce of power to
convince the usurper king Zant into
becoming a powerful minion of Ganondorf
and is therefore able to use Zant's
influence to cross back over into the
world of light from whence he was
banished where he proceeds to once again
take control of the kingdom of hyrule
the hero of Twilight and Zelda are able
to defeat him in the fields of Hyrule by
running him through with the blade of
Evil's Bane killing him the next game in
this timeline is Four Swords Adventures
which does feature a resurrected
Ganondorf however due to the nature of
the game being the only Toon Link
stylized game in the child timeline
utilizing the four sword again and
reusing the villain vaati it is some
Zelda theorists believe that this game
is actually not to be considered canon
but rather is perhaps a dream state of
sorts that takes place in the mind of
another link if Four Swords Adventures
is not a canon title or is canon but is
only a dream state game like Link's
Awakening then Ganondorf doesn't return
in the child timeline what we then
witnessed from the adult and child
timelines is the death of Ganondorf the
man who does not return later on in said
timelines neither does the beast Ganon
combining the strange pattern with what
the Commonwealth realm covered about the
Fallen timeline a little bit earlier
what can we deduce from this that will
help us understand ganondorf's
appearance in the breadth of the wild to
train
we're back to my question from earlier
we looked at Ganon's defeat in the
fallen timeline and also his continual
resurrection which is what we don't see
in the other two timelines but what's
the difference here well we don't
actually see Ganondorf the man being
killed in the Fallen timeline like we do
in the other two we see Ganon the Beast
being destroyed instead the other two
would appear to be one and the same as
shown in several cinematics such as the
ones from Twilight Princess and Ocarina
of Time but the calamity Ganon from
brought the wild and puppet Ganon from
Wind Waker both proved to us that Ganon
is a form that can be completely
detached from ganondorf's actual body
and move independently offered they also
prove that Ganon can be defeated without
necessarily doing any harm to Ganondorf
but not the other way around
now another detail to remember about
Ganondorf is that he's a rare being
indeed
he's a Gerudo which is a race
compromised of only women who've a male
being born only once a century and that
male becoming its king which is a part
of the Garuda prophecy and law that
nabooru
speaks of an ocarina of time in the game
breath of the wild we hear from a Bosa
that Ganon was once manifested in the
form of a Gerudo prior to his initial
appearance 10,000 years ago which we
know to be true knowing Ganondorf but
there's never any mention of a male from
the race having existed currently of
since if we assume that there will have
been no male Gerudo since Ganondorf or
we can still see calamity Ganon is alive
and active does this mean that a
Ganondorf from the birth dewild -
trailer was actually never killed in the
first place we can only logically deduce
from this information and what we see in
the trailer that this Ganondorf was
never actually killed but has been here
mummified immobile but alive for a very
very long time and that calamity Ganon
is his best attempt at breaking free
from whatever spell the mysterious
glowing hand has him under the next
question is which timeline does this
Ganondorf come from since we never see
Ganondorf the man died in the fallen
timeline but we do in the two others
child and adult it only seems logical to
deduce that he comes from the fallen
timeline however some do theorize that
this is the Ganondorf from Twilight
Princess
due to his chest possibly having a
cavity in the same spot as twilight
princess is Ganondorf
there is also this piece of original
concept art that appears to feature
Twilight princesses Ganondorf standing
atop a large floating piece of land now
I'm not trying to imply that breadth of
the wild comes from any one of these
timelines specifically but if you'd like
to witness a recent theory of mine
trying to explain the possible merging
of the three timelines that does mostly
line up with this theory feel free to
follow the link below but only after
checking out our other mind-blowing
theory video that's live on the
Commonwealth realms channel right now so
what happened to Ganondorf how is he
still alive after at least ten thousand
years of mummification do you have a
theory let us know all about it in the
comments below thank you so much for
watching and a huge thanks goes out to
the Commonwealth realm for helping out
with this video and letting me help out
with his thank you so much for having me
Han Mouse Nintendo bandit and also make
sure to go and check out the theory with
it on my channel huge thanks as always
to my patrons you guys are truly the
best of the best
follow the links in the description
below to find out how to get your name
up here at the end of every video and
while you're down there follow the other
link to join my amazing discord server
and chat it up with awesome people like
gamma 13 here that's all I've got for
you I hope you all have a wonderful rest
of your day
this is Maskin Hannah Bennett's signing
out free
[Music]